there's an argument that ties into that
isn't there that says still you keep you
seen as a as a protest a protest on the
immigration issue in a protest on the
European issue no one's backing you
because of the bigger policies are they
I'm sorry that is completely wrong over
a quarter of our vote are people who are
non voters who are getting back into
politics because they see you give as a
party of hope they see you give as a
party of change they see you give as a
party that wants to stand up for the
country and stand up for ordinary people
the you Kip vote is a positive
affirmation they're voting you kit
because they believe in what we stand
for and people do see you as you Kip in
essentially that there's no doubt you've
been a strong and charismatic leader and
yet still in in your constituency the
polls or those dreaded polzer they're
not looking brilliant are they that must
be quite disheartening at this stage one
with six days to go we hit a pole ten
days ago that put me nine points ahead
we had another poll two days ago that
showed me only two points ahead but
after a bit of sort of Voodoo playing of
games and re waiting to 2010 figures put
me behind look there's no question that
the battle for South panic is a big
battle and that it matters but I'm
confident that I'm going to win it back
to that for the final point I know it's
been raised before Berman do you still
stand by the comment you made to save
you if you don't if you don't win the
sea you're going to stand down unlike
the other party leaders when I say
something I mean it